[Applaudissements]
le scrutin mais non mais non le problème
leurs proches ou leurs proches
le peuple a su me fait gilles verdez
géant quelques pincées quelque part de
parler d'histoire de france et d'ignorer
l'histoire du reste du monde parce
qu'aujourd'hui on dans une conception de
l'histoire qui se veut globale et 0
grâce aux travaux des polariser les
choses c'est bien sûr j lo sûr bien sûr
que le social sont vos revendications ne
connais pas mais non est ce que je veux
dire c'est que bien sûr que je me sens
citoyen du monde
bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui les enjeux sont
planétaires et qu'il faut avoir une
autre fenêtre ouverte sur le monde
entier mais vers deux mois un citoyen du
monde
ça fait pas de moi un citoyen de nulle
part j'ai une histoire j'ai un message à
apporter j'ai des leçons à donner c'est
la même photo du père s'appelle
l'histoire de frêche vous dire laura ici
depuis comme la dégénération ou depuis
mille ans laurent blanc juste un truc
moi ce que je vais fonderont l'histoire
de fournir aux salaires ne laissons pas
justement les
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu vas faire une émission vocale
lukas sedlak en france je ferme ma
gueule
[Applaudissements]
hexagone l'exode et ganon hexagone de
montcuq l'air j'ai déjà fait rentrer
chez du chanteur sorti rejet j'ai déjà
dans mon avis parce que c'est tout ce
stress pour la chine c'était tout un
menu à mai mois de masseuse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]